with drastic changes to the Endangered  Species Act many animal habitats could  soon be destroyed leaving countless  animals without a home and without a  future  but now there's cohabitat a new  smartphone app that matches recently  displaced wildlife with local roommates  just choose your location and  preferences and Co habitat will do the  rest  most animals are relocated within a week  and after a short justement period  they'll have a new start the new  roommate and a new life without fear of  extinction or eviction Co habitat let's  make extinction a thing of the past  Co habitat is not responsible if you are  murdered eaten by your roommate and vice  versa  who was seriously bummed out by the  snake in the crib anybody no please  took six babies to get that right anyway  shows free